if you're watching love island tonight
you want to switch over because this is
more dramatic than anything love island
can give you this is political love
island in fact it's the opposite it's
political hate island where everybody
hates each other and they're all trying
to kill each other it's games of thrones
meet love island uh okay is he marked up
yet not yet okay
before we get this is extraordinary
we've got a guy from number 10 trevor
who's been sent out okay we're going to
go back to cape again i'm sorry okay ask
you my question
so
yes piers i have a question james
andrews thank you so much for joining us
always a pleasure
peters morgan has a question for you how
can boris johnson stay in office tonight
i'm happy to answer questions from you
my wife would divorce me if i took
questions from piers morgan i refuse to
go on with him because he's it's
terrible i love you you're brilliant
what question have you got from me
how can boris johnson stay in office
tonight he's seen a steady stream of
cabinet ministers turning off at his
door telling him that he needs to move
on he's seen the chairman of the 1922
committee doing exactly the same and yet
he says he's the right man for the job
so he can do it by coming out fighting
he can come out you can do it by making
quick appointments tonight we expect
appointments um he can come out by being
bold he's sacked michael gove i wasn't
in in there i don't know why but i'm
told he was sacked michael gove he's
listening to people he's going to take
action next week with his new chancellor
exchange where he's going to launch a
new economic
plan um that will include tax cuts i
don't know what type of tax cuts but
that was what he promised when he wrote
uh two mps three four-page letter that
was delivered on the vote of their
confidence following through
what does he think he's does he think
he's now britain's comical ally
yeah yeah sorry i i've got peers in in
the in the end the only person that's
comical here is him he should get well
if you can hear me if you can hear me
if you can hear me you're being i love
kate i will answer the case but i'm not
going to answer to you i think it's very
very bad tv i don't need to be different
okay really okay let me tell you what i
think of you
twerk
i think you're very bad tv yeah
is rubbish we love one another thank you
so much
i think uh i think unfortunately we've
lost our opportunity to talk to james
here but james said thank you thank you
so much let me help you unclip that
which is in your pocket there we go
quite all right but please look one of
the one of the big things there
one of the things hang on kate we can't
just pretend what happened didn't just
happen
thank you
here's one of the things there one of
the things that we did learn there well
hang on hang on okay we can't just
pretend that didn't happen who is that
guy hey who is he
uh and b how dare he be so rude who is
he
you know what i feel like i'm in the
middle of some beef that i didn't know
even existed until 10 seconds ago never
met a guy i don't know who he is who is
he
he is here to talk in support of boris
johnson well he was he was here today
but who who is he unfortunately he's uh
he's gone he's with tory mp i mean very
supportive very loyal member of boris
johnson's team yeah i mean and there are
you know
there are uh a few of them out tonight
we've heard from jacob reese can you ask
him can you ask him when we're finished
can you ask him if he'd like to bring
his wife on the show tomorrow night and
have a little two-header
look i can do my best and ask him but
he's that he's gone to speak to another
crew so i fear i may have missed my
terrible loss for this show for peter's
morgan uncensored but he is now being
called comical ali apparently all over
twitter so i think the loss is probably
more his than it is ours but uh kate
fantastic effort most entertaining thank
you for all your brilliant work tonight
uh the madness continues and uh
hopefully we'll get him and his wife on
tomorrow night um
well that's about
that's about thank you to my panel to
trevor to ava to ester thank you all
very much it's been an extraordinary
night we've had people who've been uh
had to lose their jobs for watching porn
in parliament taking the high moral
ground with gropers called pinscher
we've had aston campbell ripping his mic
off and storming off cause someone had
the affrontery to call him out god
forbid and we've had some mp i've never
heard of tell me his wife hates me and
then say he's fed up with me talking
about love island which i hate uh and
he's not gonna talk to us anymore either
quite extraordinary scenes i think my
fit apparently is a pbs to boris johnson
which must be one of the loneliest jobs
in the history of british politics
duddering dudderidge the comical alley
of world politics has decided he's too
grand to talk to me and so is his wife
well you know what i don't care because
you're not going to be in a job by next
week and i am so that's that um another
extraordinary day in british politics
the greasy piglet and his little greasy
minions remain in downing street in
their spy tonight but for how much
longer
you